bueno es en gran medida ha habido así
como un par de días el despliegue del
ferrocarril de un ferrocarril que al
parecer pertenece al décimos al décimo
segundo directorio
principal directorio décimo segundo
principal directorio del Ministerio de
defensa ruso que tiene que ver con la
manipulación el transporte y la guarda
de armas nucleares Entonces lo vieron en
movimiento y me imagino que además de
eso las declaraciones hechas por
Vladimir Putin y por quién fue su
presidente en la primera década del
siglo 21 Dimitri medbrev aparte de sus
periodistas en sus medios de prensa
sobre la posibilidad de usar armas
nucleares Incluso si bien recuerdo
contra la otan y que no están bromeando
que no están digamos que como dirían en
inglés bloofing no están simplemente
alardeando sino que lo lo pueden lo
pueden hacer entonces claro me imagino
que con el movimiento de ese convoy de
ese tren con material no sé si llevaba
armamento pero del directorio encargado
de la custodia y Transporte de armas
nucleares Además del submarino bien
goroth de la clase Andy o Oscar 2 una
versión de esa clase según la otan pues
le llaman a la clase original Oscar 2
que puede llevar el torpedo o el
vehículo no tripulado submarino Poseidón
o estatus - 6 que podría estar armado
con una ojiva de 100 megatones y un
megatón equivale un millón de toneladas
de TNT que estaría diseñado para atacar
puertos enemigos como Nueva York o
costas enemigas creando un maremoto que
arrasé con toda la costa maremoto
radiactivo que ahora sí con toda la
costa Entonces aunque este submarino
está en el mar de barence en el Ártico
el hecho de que pues ha salido no y está
en operaciones aunque digan que sea de
práctica entrenamiento preocupa preocupa
y más cuando hay derrotas en el campo de
batalla Entonces como Putin anexado esas
provincias de doñez Luján zaporilla y
jerson según la doctrina de armas
nucleares rusas si el territorio de la
federación rusa que para Putin esas
provincias ucranianas son de de la hora
o sea de Rusia si está en peligro de
integridad territorial de Rusia que ante
un ataque de armas convencionales
enemigo aunque no se usan armas
nucleares es legítimo lícito que Rusia
use armas nucleares que en este caso
podrían ser tácticas entonces es por eso
el temor que se tiene y más cuando Putin
es una persona que es despiadada y que
ha cometido crímenes contra su propia
población o sea que sería capaz de ese
tipo de acciones